we form tribes
as humans throughout human history form
tribes and have directed hate
toward other tribes
and sometimes violence and destruction
and yet tribalism allows you to tell a
story to your children allows you to
grow a culture
there's something about defining
yourself within a particular tribe yeah
that allows you to uh have a tradition
yeah um you have uh
um article that you wrote called the
case for black patriotism
oh yeah
so i should also say it's so interesting
because for me personally
i
feel identify as
believe i am an american
and yet within the american umbrella
it feels that there's a longing for
other tribes you mentioned jewish but
what i honestly feel
is i mean a lot of it is humor and
culture and so on is russian and
ukrainian because that's that's where i
come
from that's where my family is from you
know there's like
stereotypical things that are
um funny
humorous type of thing about russians
that's showing no emotion
good at chess and math
uh into wrestling uh drinking vodka i
mean this is literally every single
stereotype i'm in the embodiment of that
so there's a you celebrate that in
certain kinds of ways there's a
tradition there within the american
umbrella and some of it is humor some of
it is uh
little quarks of culture but now with
the war in russian ukraine interestingly
enough
even that little thing
it becomes also a source of
negative tribalism but anyway
that context aside
what is black patriotism
and why do you feel
i mean i'm speaking in an article called
the case for black
patriotism in a particular context
and i what i'm saying basically
is very simple i'm saying we are african
americans
and the emphasis should be on the
american
i actually don't even much care for the
framing
african-american but i'm not going to
fight with people about it it's you know
i don't think it's worth fighting about
that's not how i would just say we're
americans or if you want we're black
americans
we're certainly not african
that is the african-american population
is a population of people who come into
existence here in north america
through the cauldron of slavery
there are also immigrants immigrants
from east africa immigrants from west
africa immigrants from southern africa
immigrants from the caribbean
who descend from
an ancestral population which is african
we you know the history of the world
since 1500 is a history in which people
of african descent are scattered because
of slavery
throughout the western hemisphere
and
so here we are
but
the
institution of slavery ended in 1863 in
the united states
the struggle that we started out talking
about
which um gave rise to martin luther king
giving that speech that you say is the
greatest speech in american history and
i'm not going to argue with you about
that
happen right here in the united states
yes
we are this is what is the united states
the united
the
st
of the north american continent was
sparsely populated by an indigenous
population which was
destroyed
in conquest
by a european population that settled
here in north america and appropriated
the land
and have built a civilization here
which has been peopled by a large influx
of individuals from
europe to irish and italian and greek
and slavic and
jewish russian jews coming in large
numbers and so on in wave after wave
after wave of immigration
asian
latin american population of people who
have come
to reside here in the united states and
we black americans who descend from
slaves
we african americans who descend from
slaves so here we are
this is a great nation i mean this is a
monumentally significant
political
force which is the united states of
america founded in
um 1776 1787
uh
fought a war of independence from the
british uh established a republic which
is a
uh
confederation of these independent
colonies which has grown into now the 50
states of the united states of america
continental nation
the
richest
and most powerful nation on the planet
with massive influence throughout the
world
for good and for ill
that's who we are i want to say to black
people
there is no other home for us
this fantasy
of we being a people apart
back in the day when i was coming along
in the 1960s there was something called
the republic of new africa
movement and they wanted some states in
the south giving over to black people
and we were going to have our own
country
and that's a it's a joke it's a fantasy
it's it's uh it's it's a mythic
uh
uh un
uh
balanced uh unrealistic
uh
uh fanciful
politics it's not a serious politics
we're americans we're not going anywhere
here
the idea that
and i want to say this in a number of
different registers i want to say first
of all
we need to make peace with the fact that
that's who we are and that's where we
are so uh
nobody is coming
the world court is not going to litigate
our disputes uh the united nations is
not going to set up a desk for people of
african descent who reside in north
america
we have to work out whatever our
concerns are with our fellow americans
right here within the context of
american politics
that means compromise
that means looking for frame a framework
for political expression which is
broader than our racial identity
etc so i i want to say that but i also
want to say there's no reason to
apologize for this there's something
positive to a firm i take on this
question about slavery on in in brief in
brief
because in fact slavery was awful and it
was wrong and it was on the backs of the
enslaved africans and it had
consequences that endured
that have endured long after the
termination of the thing but i also want
to say
look at what has happened in the last
150 years for african americans
and i want to say
look at the
vitality of the institutions here in the
united states of america of the
democratic republic of the united states
of america
again not perfect
which are which are malleable enough
these institutions to allow for the
transformation of the status of african
americans such as has occurred
since the end of slavery
and i want to say there's a lot to
celebrate in that
so
this is our country
we are uh full members of the polity
uh we have
uh burdens and responsibilities as well
as privileges that are associated with
our membership in this republic
that does not mean that we should not
fight for what we believe to be right
although we are not one
voice here we black americans it does
not mean that we should not protest
things that we think are deserving of
protest
but i want to say it does mean that we
should not
reject the
framework that we're operating in
because we basically don't have any
alternative and because when viewed in
full context
a noble and profoundly
significant achievement the united
states of america and a beacon
uh to the rest of the world i don't want
to
you know go off in some starry eyed kind
of
jingoistic celebration of america as the
greatest civilization etc etc
but this great nation
uh is um
our
nation
and i think we do best
by beginning we black americans do best
by beginning this is my argument in the
piece by beginning
but from a framework which accepts that
fact
and then builds on it
so black patriotism is
it's not exactly the same
rhymes
echoes american patriotism
so a black american is first and
foremost an american yeah
a black american is first and foremost
an american
and it's a good thing too
let me return
to the question of dr king
and another
powerful impactful individual malcolm x
to ask you the question
well first
people often perhaps inaccurately
uh portray them as
representing two different ideals
approaches
to the fight for civil rights
so martin luther king for the
non-violent approach
the peacemaker and malcolm x
is the by any means necessary
what do you think about this distinction
and broadly speaking in black patriotism
in the future
of black americans in the 21st century
what is the role of anger
what is the role of
protest
even
you know violence encompasses a lot of
things but just aggression
and the you know [ __ ] the man we're
going to have to make change force
change
okay i think you put your finger on
something really important in the
context of we were just discussing my
black patriotism essay and
um
it's not the only it's not the only
story
there there is another story and malcolm
x is someone you identify and his
memory
lives on and is powerfully influential
uh and i think you see it in black lives
matter and i think you see it in the
protest and rioting and so forth
that has broken out periodically going
all the way back to the 1960s and before
but especially
since uh the 1960s
he saw it in los angeles in 1992
in the rodney king civil disturbances
that
broke out there
and the the balled up fist
the radical
uh
afrocentric
rejection of the
uh american
story that martin luther king he
believed in he believed in a magnificent
promissory note
and a lot of people are rolling their
eyes you know and saying you know as you
say [ __ ] the man magnificent promissory
note
i mean just get your knee off my neck
that's what you can do for me don't ask
me to believe in your bs about some
magnificent promises you know some
founding fathers
who were all slave owners anyway i mean
just get your knee off my neck
now
i can relate to that uh as i mentioned i
grew up in chicago in the 1950s and the
1960s i remember malcolm x i mean
literally in real time
i remember when he was murdered
in 1965 in the audubon
ballroom
in harlem in manhattan in
new york city
um
i remember my uncle i i was raised in a
house where my aunt and uncle were the
master of the house and my mother and my
sister and i lived in a small
apartment upstairs in the back of this
of this big house that my successful
aunt and uncle owned
and my uncle was a small businessman a
barber and
a tradesman
he was he was a hustler i mean legally
he did what he had to do to make money
he was a very enterprising
not especially well-educated but
a very intelligent and
disciplined
um and resourceful
provider for his family which included
myself my
sister and my mother in their household
and we called him uncle mooney because
he had moon-shaped eyes that protruded
and were around uncle mooney
uh james
ellis was his name uncle mooney
james ellis lee
almost my uncle mooney but i'm saying
all that to say this
he admired the nation of islam
i mean
king
and malcolm x martin king and malcolm x
differed along a number of different
dimensions malcolm x was a muslim
and martin luther king jr was a
christian minister
my uncle mooney
didn't have any time for these christian
ministers
he thought that was the white man's
religion
he you know and back in that day you go
into a black church and you'd see a
portrait of jesus and he'd be a
blonde hair blue-eyed yeah
he didn't even look like uh like a
mediterranean he didn't i mean he didn't
look like somebody who came from uh
palestine i mean he looked like somebody
who came uh from northern europe or
something like that the picture of jesus
and my uncle mooney rejected that whole
thing he would be damned if he was going
to bend his knee to some white jesus
but he was not a muslim either
but he respected the muslims he brought
home their newspaper it was called
muhammad speaks this is the nation of
islam
which is the black muslim movement
founded
in
american cities in detroit and in
chicago
going back to the early middle 20th
century
and growing into a very significant
movement uh that had a lot of influence
louis farrakhan and the controversial
figure
descends from this movement it has
uh fractured now and
has the major part of the legacy of the
black muslims
has assimilated itself into islam uh
proper uh malcolm x made a
famous pilgrimage to mecca and medina
and came back with a very different
vision about what it meant to be a
muslim and
understood himself to be a part of the
large tradition and religious
culture of islam that has a global reach
and he he had a different vision when he
came back from that
some people say that's why he was killed
and so on um i don't know
i certainly find that to be plausible
that he
came to constitute a threat to the sect
which was the
the black muslims and i had to be had to
be dealt with
uh i don't know if we'll ever know the
full story on that
but anyway what i'm trying to say is
the black muslims were there malcolm x
was there and in my
experience
uh they constituted a counterpoint
to the position of king which depended
on a kind of respect
for the best of the tradition
of american democracy
appealing to the better nature
of our oppressors live up to the full
meaning
of our creed i mean these are words that
he would use a magnificent promissory
note is what he would think of as the
declaration of independence and
the legacy of abraham lincoln
unfulfilled ideal
and
the black muslims were like
[ __ ] that
we're going to take care of our own
we we're going to build our own schools
we're going to build our own businesses
uh
we're we're not waiting for the white
man to do anything get your knee off my
neck and get out of my way and let me
take care of my own
and my uncle respected that he respected
the straight back
the the the stand up straight with your
shoulders back that's a jordan peterson
but i mean that was
way before jordan peterson but that was
his philosophy stand up straight but
just raise your children don't be
depending upon welfare you taking
welfare from the white man you need to
get busy you need to educate yourself
you need to clean up your act put down
the fried chicken because it's going to
kill you
my uncle mooney
loved this book
that elijah muhammad
they called him the honorable elijah
muhammad was the founder
and the leader of the nation of islam he
had a book and all the books said was
be smart eat green vegetables
don't eat fried food
don't eat pork they're muslims don't eat
pork
and take responsibility for your diet
and be healthy and uh you know don't be
putting a whole lot of pills into your
body you don't need to do that if you
just get control of your diet and you
you know you eat probably you know my
uncle loved this idea
of responsibility for self
and a determination to build uh you know
he
he respected that in the muslims even if
he didn't
by the religious part of it
and so
and and by the way when my uncle died
uh in 1983
he left me a bequest
it wasn't money unfortunately
it was his complete collection of the
recorded speeches of malcolm x
and i have i have these albums these are
33 and a third lps there's six of them
uh and i have a complete collection as
best as my uncle could assemble the
recorded speeches of malcolm x now why
did he do that he did that because he
did not want me to forget don't be
dependent upon the white man build your
own
stand up straight with your shoulders
back
proud black man take care of your
business take care of your children pick
up the trash in front of your house
uh
get busy
th this was this philosophy
uh so
violence now
that's another story i mean malcolm x
would say you know
we're going to defend ourselves you're
going to mess with us you know you
racist ku klux klan or whatever we're
going to arm ourselves
and we're going to fight you back you
racist police who are
uh oppressing and persecuting and
abusing our people well
you better be ready because we're going
to fight you back
and
that too was a spirit that my uncle that
was a kind of attitude a kind of posture
uncle was not a radical he was he was a
businessman but he respected this idea
you uh
take your life in your own hands when
you mess with us because we're prepared
to defend ourselves
so that blood runs in you too that
threat is when you write about black
patriotism that threat is there too
it's like
you embody both the ideal that we're all
american
but also
that there is this oppressive history
there there is the powerful
that
are
manipulating you
that are oppressing you
and you can't just wait around for
things to fix themselves
you have to take action
you have to take things into your own
hands and sometimes that means being
angry sometimes that means being violent
that's there too
yeah it's there but
um here in in the butt is
i don't me today glenn lowry in 2022
think that
that is the answer i i don't think that
violent rebellion
gets us anywhere at the end of the day
i i think we're past
that
uh there there aren't night rider ku
klux klan uh people breaking down your
door and dragging you away there are not
uh nooses throw thrown over a tree uh
limb
uh where you hang somebody from the tree
because they whistled at a white woman
or they
got too much property in your community
and you became you know they were uppity
negroes and whatnot like that that is
a thing of the past in america that the
uh
situation is no longer the one that
requires that kind of
violent reaction and that
there there is if we look at the net
effect of the so-called rebellions
in american cities
they're negative
the the
george floyd
protests which became violent and
arsonists in the aftermath of civil
disturbance and whatnot in the summer of
2020 i think set back
the program for african americans i
don't think it advanced it
i think there are things to be
concerned about
schools that are not working
uh police that are not not respecting
citizens and so forth but i think that
those are things
that affect
white americans as well and that the way
to
ultimately
correct
those things
is to
uh
make uh
alliance and associate oneself with
americans who are concerned to change
these things and i don't think it's
properly framed as a racial
um as a racial problem and i certainly
don't think
that uh
you know violent
rebellion
uh gets us anywhere i i'm you know i i
get the historical
salience of that posture
and it made a lot of sense
in the early in the mid 20th century
i don't think it makes very much sense
at all in the early 21st century
you